so I've just had an excellent talk on
indistinguishability obfuscation I want
to talk about black box office keishon
so that was this prep someone more
ambitious school and so to recap the
setting is we have some classical
functionality implemented by circuit see
we'd like to map it to some encrypted
circuit there's some obfuscated did
circuit see which satisfies two
properties so one it also be useful by
which I mean given the encoding of C and
some input X I would like to be able to
evaluate see at the input x + 2 so this
was property one and property to was
that any interaction with this encoded
circuit can be simulated using black box
access to see
so as was pointed out it's not exactly
clear how we would formalize this what
does it mean to simulate some
interaction with this data using a black
box access doesn't fit into the normal
model and besides this is sort of known
to be impossible classically for any
reasonable notion of simulation so we
should settle for indistinguishable you
obfuscation which hides everything that
it's possible to hide the approach i'm
going to take instead is to imagine that
this application is a quantum state so
this does two things one is it allows us
to get around the classical
impossibility result a second one is
that actually gives us a very nice
notion of what what we mean to simulate
this interaction namely I can say any
measurement can be simulated
so from my perspective I have this
quantum state I have some instruments
that designed to measure the state for
all I know that quantum state isn't
really a quantum state inside it there's
some simulator who has black box access
to this functionality see and whenever I
make a measurement he's just telling me
what the measurement result ought to be
and if this were the case then I think
we could say in some very strong sense
that interacting with this quantum state
is no more useful than interacting with
the black box which implements that
functionality a little certainly will be
have to be very careful if you want to
compose this than males and throughout
I'm going to be talking about
computationally bounded interaction
computationally bounded simulators and
computational indistinguishability the
results so if a feed ask you any
questions about the model what is the
black box case so see with some
classical functionality so the black box
was just to submit X you learned the
value of CX
like just education yeah so that will
not be I mean it's going to be
completely unclear what the security of
the scheme is the rest of the talk is
going to consist of a presentation of a
scheme which plausibly meets this
guarantee and some discussion will not
be clear with the security guarantees
it's not clear if you obfuscate two
circuits if the obsessions interact
appropriately you have an obfuscation
that automatically work ah not
automatically you may be able to do some
quantum like some unitary transformation
that combines your two up this kitchen
so this guarantee in itself wouldn't be
good yeah so do i understand invite that
in point to you kind of model the state
as a machine and you have to send to it
like commands like i do this unitary i
perform a measurement in that basis and
it's actually the simulator sitting
there so the energy I put the columns
that another and in fact there is no
quantum state array by phone i call the
experiment of what to do I mean once I
think there's a real experiment and the
other a simulator that's exactly right
so you can you can also have some
quantum workspace if you like and the
simulator will also be running that
workspace so another interesting
possibility that comes up in this case
in which also doesn't exist in the
classical case was that this this office
gated circuit may not even be copyable
so I may be able to produce this is an
idea that Sutter instant first raised
and this is all based in large part on
joint work with stop and but it may be
that if I give you this this
implementation of the program you cannot
produce to working implementations of
scene so you just get one program the
program is really acting like a black
box you can't learn anything from it and
also you can't produce two black boxes
so the basic approach is going to be
based on I garbled circus perhaps
familiars many of us sir it's not the
idea in a garbled circuit is that we
take each wire of the circuit see and
for each wire or two each wire we
associate a pair of Secrets one secret
corresponding to the input zero and one
secret corresponding to the input one
for example on this wire I'll say we
have s 0 0 and s 01 on this wire we have
s 10 and s11 and so on and similar to
the internal wires that's 30 that's 3 1
etc so in a garbled circuit for every
water there's a pair of Secrets one
secret corresponds to 0 1 secret
corresponds to one um I don't distribute
those secrets with the garbled circuit
so ideally the way in which a garbled
circuit is used is I provide to the user
or to someone exactly one of each pair
of Secrets corresponding to the input on
which they want to evaluate that circuit
and I provide for each gate some data
which allows me to take the secrets
associate to the input wires and produce
the secret associated to the output wire
so if this is supposed to be an and gate
if you have the two secrets
corresponding to one on the input wires
you should be able to use those in
combination with the data I supplied to
extract the secret corresponding to one
on the output wire similarly if you of
the two secrets course fine 20 you
should be able to extract the secret
correspond to zero and so on so once you
have in hand one secret for each of the
input wires you can sort of go through
recursively and compute the secret for
everyone including the secret for the
output wire so we have s out 0s at one
you ultimately obtain exactly one of
these two secrets and then I also
provide you some data which allows you
to distinguish between these two secrets
which corresponds to learn in the output
of the circuit
questions yes so this is sort of a
quantum analog one-time program so we
can't actually make a one-time program
but we can make a program which you can
sort of only have one copy oh listen I
have to measure it you can actually you
can undo we can sort of can't stop you
from measuring it and then it sticks
around and you can measure it again
later if the measurement is
deterministic so actually this program
is just you can use it just like an
obfuscation of a possible application of
a program accept any measurement you
make can be simulated by the black box
access and maybe you can't copy it that
would be cool requiring that you get the
output with certainty there's no
degradation of the program state yet the
program state will be about going to say
I'm at the beginning an end and maybe
they'll be some exponential degradation
but exponentially small degradation the
problem so the basic frame we're going
to try and use to do that is this side
carpal circuit okay the way in which we
would use a garbled circuit for
obfuscation ideally is we would imagine
we have some universal circuit we have
some inputs that our program inputs or a
description of the program which we want
to run we have some inputs which are the
real inputs to the program the person
who wants to produce the obfuscating
circuit supplies the secrets
corresponding to the program which they
want you to be able to run so the inputs
corresponding to
see are provided
and then somehow one out of two of each
of these is provided
and so if you have the inputs
corresponding to the program and you
have one out of two of each of the
actual input secrets you can obtain the
secret corresponding to the output so
this is the overall plan using this to
you obtain see Chris responding to
output
and then we'll give you some data that
allows you to turn that secret
corresponding the output into either 0
or 1 depending on whether the circuit
return 0 but classically this is not a
sensical proposal for obfuscating a
circuit because what does it mean to
give you some data which allows you to
get exactly one of the two input secrets
it doesn't make any sense classically if
you were able to get one of the secrets
for this wire on one execution and then
get the second secret for this wire on
the second execution you could just get
both secrets and if you have both
secrets in this garbled circuit
construction then it just looks like a
normal circuit so the core problem will
be can we use quantum mechanics that
somehow implement this plan which didn't
make any sense classically so there any
questions about that plan which I could
potentially clear
so this is going to involve three
ingredients ingredient one is some way
to do this non-interactive one out of
two transfer again is a primitive that
really doesn't make any sense
classically and taken literally it's
also impossible quantumly we can
hopefully do it well enough the second
ingredient is some data to transform
input secrets into output secrets
and the third step some data to
interpret Apple the output wire secret
so I would like to do is I'd like to
provide some implementation of each of
these three steps I think step one is
probably the most mysterious see means
for them to start with that one and so
how can I provide some data to you which
allows you to get exactly one out of two
secrets but not get both and what you
can use over and over again
so that is the ideal situation we have
some state sigh which I gave you you can
use the state to extract some secret one
or some secret zero and you can use the
state to abstract some secret one but
you can't extract this so intuitively
you might hope that you could say encode
secret zero in the position of some
particle and encode secret one in the
momentum of some particle and there
would be possible to either measure as
zero or measure s one but not both yeah
so one problem is if that's your own s 1
or just two secrets it's necessarily the
case but if there's some measurement
that extracts s 0 with probability 1 I
can just make that measurement and then
recover my original state because it
hasn't done any damage and so it's sort
of if everything that's going on
deterministically yields the output of
the circuit then I can always run this
process to get the output of the circuit
rewind this process and be back where I
started and then do it again so that
means that I can't this is not an
achievable goal I can't allow you get
one secret or another deterministically
been out though so the problem with this
scheme is that you were
deterministically extracting the secret
the thing we'd like to do is we'd like
to have the secret speed there could be
several possible secrets and you extract
one of them stochastically and this
means that when you actually learn what
the secret is you will have done some
damage to the input it's a little bit
more clear I'm going to provide you some
states I such that using sigh you can
either extract an element of one space
is ear or you can extract an element of
a different space a one fact these are
going to be a linear subspace
what yeah so over cover up to the end
so I'm going to imagine now that for
every wire I have some vector space and
the secrets associates that wire are two
subspaces which are typically going to
be very sparse subspaces in order to do
computation what you need is not a
description of the entire subspace you
just need a vector from that subspace
that's going to be the basic approach as
in the garbled circuit construction we
have two secrets or a pair of secrets
for every wire you can recursively if
you have an element from the appropriate
subspaces you can use them to get
elements from the subspaces lower down
the circuit and eventually at the end
you either get an element from the
subspace or an element from that
subspace and I'll give you some data to
let you tell which one you got and
you've evaluated the circuit nope these
are just this is a subspace of
opportunity and you should imagine
intuitively yeah the density of the
subspace is very small so exponentially
yeah that's how it's this subspace is a
secret and if you're in fact there's no
way you can possibly recover the
description the subspace but it's yeah
okay so this is how I'm going to try and
do step one okay you're right I haven't
described what the state is I mean
there's a classical secrets I want to
give you some quantum state which allows
you to recover exactly one of these two
objects you can recover either a vector
in this some space or vector in that
subspace you can't get both because when
you recover it if you actually get this
vector it'll destroy your original state
so in fact what the state is going to be
the states sigh is just going to be um
the sum over all the vectors in the
subspace
so I will give you a uniform
superposition over elements of the
subspace if you want to recover a vector
from the subspace you can just measure
from that's your position and you'll get
a uniformly random element from the
subspace I'll take a one to be the
orthogonal complement of these so if I
want to get out element a1 all i have to
do is take the Hadamard transform of
this and measure that basically if I
measure the position of this thing I get
a random vector of a zero if I measure
the momentum I get a random vector in
the Atacama compliment that's how I'm
going to do this one out of two transfer
it seems like a one is huge right ah so
in this case let's imagine that both of
these have dimension and over 2 so for
the input wire these two subspaces are
complementary and they have like half of
thighs so sorry I'm a little confused
here so you want it you want to be able
to execute your program on any choice of
multiple inputs when I executed multiple
times right so that's going to be
guaranteed automatically so when I run
I'm gonna do everything in evaluating
the circuit in quantum superposition at
the end I'm going to extract a bit 0 1
an app it is going to be deterministic
so it's only there was going to 0 is
gonna be one depending what if it's a
chose and that guarantees that i can
always uncompressed did end up back
where I started and then it will be
fresh to use again so so I minute I
talked about this as measuring you're
not really going to be measuring your is
gonna be manipulating that quantity in
quantity okay sorry that's a bit
linguistically variant thank you ok so
now I'm gonna look at three um three
assorted very very easy compared to two
but it'll be a building block that will
let us do to do you have a proof that if
you extract the zero that you can't get
v1 correct ah yeah so that can be proved
i'm going to prove it or talk about
pretty much harder thing in one second I
don't yeah so that actually can be
proved just by looking at the inner
product between these states you don't
look can prove you can't get both an
element of this and an element of the
world yeah we need something much much
stronger than that naturally to make the
skin go ok
so for step three I want to allow you to
identify an element of this subspace or
this subspace so they want to provide I
want to provide this function from v2 is
V a member of a I'd like you to I'd like
to give you basically an obfuscated
inform of this function so that you can
use it as a black box to evaluate that
membership that you can't use it to
about anything else and so this is where
we have to make some computational
assumption I don't know what the best
one is I can make one I'm a little bit
scared every time I like use this
assumption because of some probability
someone in the audience will be able to
break it I tried a long time and I
couldn't and that's really the best
evidence I have that it's a good
assumption um what I'm going to do is
I'm going to pick a random degree 3
polynomial P of x equals the sum alpha
IJ K xixj X K such that P of V equals 0
for all DNA
oh well
I'm going to choose a uniformly random
polynomial which vanishes on this entire
subspace it turns out that i can do that
just by doing the change of basis so
that a is supported on some unit vectors
picking random like including each
monomial that vanishes on they with
probability half and then performing the
change of basis back and then my
encryption is going to be a set of that
will also be if so a minimal assumption
is I've given you the set of polynomials
I would not a lot about you now to be
able to recover the identity of the
subspace a for example if these were
degree two polynomials you could really
just read off a from the polynomial when
their degree 3 polynomial I don't it
doesn't seem to be known how to do this
oh yeah this is all this was a subspace
opportunity
okay so I'm just going to assume this
behaves like a black box frankly if I
could assume this and then prove the
scheme secure I would be in a much
better position that I currently am
things are going to get my assumptions
are going to get more tenuous by the end
I think the goal is basically proving
security under this assumption sorry
that was completely unclear i'll give
you a set of n such polynomials you can
then test membership by evaluating all
of them if they're all 0 your na if
you're not in a then with the
overwhelmingly high probability you'll
find a non 0 1 this is this edge it's an
obfuscated area for this function yeah
and to be clear that again the office
cater is test all of these see how many
of them are zero you could also add
noise if you wanted like I can give you
order n polynomial such that like one
percent of them vanished on em and you
could just check for statistics maybe
that's harder to break I don't know so
even assuming this is a black box the
security of the scheme is going to be
going to be a very hard for a complexity
problem currently open
but here's a minimal question um minimal
question is if I give you a which is the
uniform superposition over elements of a
and I give you this encoding of a
membership function for a and an
encoding of a membership function for
the orthogonal complement today I want
the secrets for these input wires to be
a pair of orthogonal complimentary
subspaces so minimal question is if I
give you this input data and I give you
these two membership functions can you
find an element of a and it dual
simultaneously when you say buell
assumption you mean an assumption that
is necessary if this were false then the
scheme would definitely definitely be
destroyed maybe something that even more
philly necessary and we could say can
you produce the states
even this is not obvious but that we can
rule yeah so this is something i can't
real discussion but yes the scallions
and i have in the paper and quantum
money and so this is not you cannot
produce such a state well not without
exponentially many queries yes and so
the way this proof go is one looks at
for the execution of such a cloning
algorithm in parallel on two subspaces
which overlap that are not identical and
then monitor the inner product between
the states produced by those two
algorithms over time it can't drop much
the nerdy clone has to drop a lot i'm
also connects quickly how long this talk
should be it was originally budgeted for
30 minutes okay
plenty of time okay so this is going to
be the data that I'm going to provide at
the end of the game so when we get to
the last wire this output wire I'm going
to use this membership Oracle in order
to decide whether I lie in the subspace
correspond to 0 it's those fits
corresponding to 1 i'm going to say
nothing more than this is the only query
complexity bound for that window site in
the entire sorry ok so what remains is
how did you just step 2 um I go to give
a step to security I can't analyze which
I think at least looks possible again
which one cannot very easily attack so
the setting is we have some gate we have
on the inputs two pairs of subspaces we
have on the output wire a pair of
subspaces I would like to give you some
data which allows you to start from the
in AI W in and then map to some you in c
g i comma j g IJ is the result of this
skate applied to those implants so the
question is just what data can I provide
it allows you to do this without giving
up the identity of these subspaces
so intuitively what we'd like to do is
we'd like to have some random we'd like
to provide random linear maps f IJ from
AI direct sum j to see so recall that
this was living in F 2 to the N this was
living these were living in f2 to the
end this direct project or direct some
lives in F to the 2n so I'd like to just
be able to provide some random linear
map out of this direct sum into the
appropriate subspace down here and then
you could run sort of all four of these
functions see which one corresponds to
see which one gives you a nonzero value
or which one your input was in the
domain of and then take the
corresponding output so a problem with
that approach is that it leaks the
identity of the function that you need
if I give you these four independent
functions and you get to see which of
the four functions actually yielded a
value then you can run your circuit on
two independent inputs for each one
learn which of these four functions sort
of worked which of the four functions
return to non zero value and and as a
results figure out whether the two
inputs involved the same values on these
wires which would be which would break
the superior of the protocol so we need
to do is we need to allow you to compute
this output but make it so that if you
observe any fact about how the output
was computed it destroys the inputs to
the circuit that's our challenge you
want to make it so that as you evaluate
the function if you learn anything
non-negligible it will damage your
inputs enough but before you've learned
anything about the whole circuit you've
destroyed your inputs entirely I think
I've gone over time I'm sorry
five minutes five more minutes okay I'll
just provide the scheme so idea one is
the F inverse F i J inverse of rather
this is a linear subspace the set of X
in AI plus BJ such that f IJ of X has
cape coordinate one or Cape coordinate 0
this is a linear subspace and so we're
assuming that I can manufacture
membership Oracle's for these subspaces
let's call these subspaces I don't know
dij ok so one thing I could do which
we've just asserted wouldn't work would
be to provide for each pair IJ so 00 01
10 11 and each value of can fool all n
values of K I could provide one Oracle
which would tell you membership for in d
IJ okay
so i could give you this big grid of
input values and or membership Oracle's
if i gave you this grid and you were
given a vector um you can run the vector
through all of these membership Oracle's
at most one of these rows would contain
any non any nonzero values you would
take that rail and you can just read off
f IJ of your input from the results of
membership Oracle's in every room and
then the i coordinate so your output
should be 1 if all of these Oracle's
return true are there should be 0 all
these Oracle's returning true and one
otherwise so if something in fact has
value zero then one of these will return
true and the rest will return false if
it has value one doll return false
so I can use this set of 4k or 4n
membership Oracle's to evaluate my
function so I can use it to go from this
pair of inputs to this output this was
not suitable because I can tell which
row I use so i can tell which row my
info waters correspond to ago this rail
has nonzero values and it must be the
case that the inputs 401 which is too
much information for me to learn so this
very simple change to make to fix that
which is just randomly this output only
depends on the count of ones in this
call so i can just go through every
column it randomly permute the
membership Oracle's in that column and
that's all the dad I'm going to give you
so using that data you can then compute
for any elements in any of these four
subspaces formed as direct direct sums
you can find the appropriate element in
the output or in the secret
corresponding the alkyl are okay I think
I'm out of time and have run over that
was a very brief explanation possible if
I can answer some all there were
questions to clarify should do that but
otherwise thinking questions oh so I
guess this already written up I'll
published I I have no guarantees I
worked for a long time trying to prove
guarantees I should probably just give
up and look a bit I don't have a
write-up sorry I don't have a published
author
okay so let's thank all again